moody's allons les titres de ce journal
les couples de la région parisienne font
de plus en plus d'enfants c'est l'une
des principales informations d'une étude
publiée ce matin par l'insee de plus en
plus d'enfants
à tel point que pour la première fois
l'île de france se situe au dessus de la
moyenne nationale
la palme des bébés reviennent au val
d'oise et la seine saint denis chiffres
et analyse valérie noir les femmes des
villes ont aujourd'hui plus d'enfants
que les femmes deschamps résultat un
enfant virgule 78 en moyenne provinciale
1,82 pour une parisienne
c'est le véritable retournement de
tendance à ces dernières années en 1983
la fécondité pour plus forte en province
qu'en ile de france c'est l'inversé
aujourd'hui les raisons de ce changement
c'est probablement que les couples
aujourd'hui quand ils veulent un enfant
tiennent compte de l'existence le de
services par exemple les crèches et
haltes-garderies or c'est dans les
villes qu'on va trouver ces équipements
l'insee a même enregistré des disparités
entre les départements de la région
peu d'enfants à paris explication les
femmes résulte souvent seuls dans la
capitale de nombreux bébés en revanche
en seine-saint-denis et dans le
val-d'oise de départements où vit une
importante population étrangère ou
ouvrières yvelines et seine et marne
sont également au dessus de la moyenne
pour les chercheurs cela s explique par
le cadre de vie et la taille du logement
de la grande banlieue
autres résultats de cette enquête l'âge
moyen de la maman à la naissance de son
premier bébé 28 ans en province 29 dans
la région et même 30 ans à paris la
raison essentielle c'est que à paris les
femmes ont un niveau d'études plus élevé
sur des études plus longues et que de ce
fait là évidemment la maternité et
retarde autre phénomène typiquement
régionale 2 fois plus de bébés à paris
qu'en province pour les femmes qui ont
dépassé les 40 ans les mamans sont
souvent des divorcés qui veulent ou d un
nouveau foyer
enfin près d'un enfant sur trois naît
hors mariage c'était traditionnellement
une habitude parisienne aujourd'hui sur
ce point la province a rattrapé la
capitale